fix this one graphic z 2 3 4 5 okay six
seven eight nine Jackson is okay all
right here you go yeah we're going on
buzzing yeah we're going we're going
we're going right away everybody round
two [ __ ] we left off with Darryl face
will start with Glenn face ah come on
I've got so much editing to do yeah you
jokes go over and lick that fire no so
Elvis oh stop it Tehran yeah climb in
there climb in this hole you'll be safe
holes we go stop saying that do you feel
safe yet yeah like Oh hold all these
dust particles really late much you
speak louder absolutely not yours are
gonna be so very badly I just not being
able to you or to say okay okay okay I'm
gonna be mad at you cuz i have to edit
this and I have to make what you say
legible have to put all subtitles the
plot isn't here no oh the plots gone
still more story than destiny still
twist or you've invested even with us
even with us you know you wake up go hey
what's going on space do it again I'm
dead that alien just pushed you down
using his telekinesis you learn that
from mr. Shepard mastership master
Shepherd is that what you call him what
okay rebels ooh cool
stop yes but still every hole you see in
this game you're supposed to climb no
stop just keep going still what are you
doing you stop in progress next gen
technology look at all these cloth
physics look at these buckles just
bounce it all over it's like Final
Fantasy oh me oh you always know where
to go to the show is that the name of
your new album it's always the name of
body well I have 20 albums only Oh Kane
can you not read hey keep moving it's
not a gameplay mechanic yeah you got him
off we you're not scavenging very good
no I don't have all of stuff down here
No haha we're gonna sign hold on haha
thanks face it's like those posters and
dead space where it's just a picture of
a guy of the stick figure floating
around in the sky and it says be careful
in zero gravity dumbass yeah yo good
that switch go ahead for breath res I
just had a minor stroke let's get out of
here it's sinking the titanic ii
thinking Carl car all and then insert
picture of spider-man doing something
hilarious primarily not caring about the
situation at hand turn my spooky 5 turn
right again right turn right
no I can't be productive story story
kill the power kill the power turn on
the power ahahaha killing her hair
gameplay this isn't funny the audience
is getting upset there you go now look
down at that that creepy hallway let's
get out of here Scoob then just cut you
to them being chased by the Aileen and a
bunch of big hallways and like running
in and out of doors on separate sides of
the hallway so it doesn't make a whole
lot of sense right ok cool go forward or
forward forward left part laughs now do
it now you do right stick your your nose
in the buttons nope no there is a code
that you saw tell you saw on the thing
oh but all right price select is the
journal button give me the controller so
he can stop looking at his key code why
are you doing this for like movies jus
teenagers not doing anything useful
there just talking and not oh my gosh I
are having a space seizure hahaha you're
done no no your progress look check this
out check out this progress see I'm
running I'm moving at a pay f you f you
dancin no you know you if you crotch
while running you do a sweet slide
tackle move see
alright I will make all the progress you
know here no we can't be doing stop
touching the microphone check out this
space airport no the skybox no sky boxes
and it's your space hey hey hey yes you
look at him daddy you don't look at me
now look at Mary kids see Jackson
Jackson Louisville what do the numbers
mean Mason don't know first barista
don't move Oh try to trick I'm bison
making you think that would be spooky no
entry okay this sex hey Jackson guess
what the meaning of life is to right
behind you 42 yeah Karen yes yeah sorry
sorry sorry sorry I hi Canadian Space
you sorry it's a Canadian spaceship they
felt bad for writing on the wall so they
said sorry I'm gonna find save estoppel
safe estoppel we have done nothing of
value for like fairies will be shocked
luma na me which are on Sky box skyboxes
beaten on Sky box I'm not gonna give you
back your face I'll get skin my skin
such a much kinder
situation oh yeah back here awesome no
no you're in a different place that also
has that to go back down those stairs
and turn left turn left yes yes